how is it that reality shows are Dumber
now than I remember them being I've met
the person I want to spend the rest of
my life with here you will choose
someone to marry Hello nice to hear from
you I can't say see ya without ever
seeing
if you're ready to find the love of your
life
game time the pods are now open what are
some of your biggest turn-offs so what
are you looking for in a woman ethnicity
race physical appearance none of that
matters I'm really starting to
emotionally connect with you this could
be a remarkable Love Story we're gonna
match a bunch of Attractive people up
and have them get married even though
they haven't seen each other I wonder
what will happen we know what happened
they'll get divorced by next Thursday
that's what's going to happen second of
all the drama and suspense is taken out
because they're all relatively
attractive for a concept like this to
work you need to mix in some some ugly
ducklings you should have like a guy
who's 600 pounds and they wheel them out
on a forklift for the big reveal that
would be high drama